hey ladies
I want to pause that question yeah that
was in the Super Chat yeah what do you
bring to a man because we're talking
about
um the expectations of women blah blah
blah we've gone over it over it and more
than likely if I ask you like the same
question you're gonna say the same stuff
so what do you think
you bring to a man that wants you to
have like high expectations of a man
like what do you think what do you bring
to the man oh and before that and with
that
um tell you tell us your name age and
your relationships that's talking to the
mic talk into the mic you're moving you
can call me Rue
and I'm 26 years old and
um what do I bring to a man
peace happiness everything you need
okay yeah that's fair enough nothing
else nothing else like that's what you
provide for me like
it depends what you provide for me oh it
depends though yeah no it depends
because if you're not a nice person and
you don't treat me right and you don't I
don't know like
you don't give me what I want now I can
see you looking at me you don't give me
what I want then no I don't have to you
know so why are you even involved if the
guy's not giving you what you want why
are you even involved with him in the
first place no when you date you get to
know people there's you take time to
know people you can't just date people
and then be like oh yeah I want you and
I expect this from you so when your day
when you're dating a guy and you're not
sure if he's giving you what you want
then so you get time you get time to
know people obviously you know what you
want in your head but obviously you have
to get what do you do
what do I want in a guy you have to be
respectful God-fearing
and just yourself do you go to church
yeah I do go to church that's good man
thank you cool next one no I'll say that
I did yeah I'm 44 years old I'm Jessica
and what do I want from a man what can I
provide for a man yeah right I can
provide properties
I am a mother of three I'm a good mother
I can cook I can clean I'm also very
educated and
um yeah I don't expect a lot from a guy
except for loyalty and kindness and
respect
yeah yeah
that's it and I'm a woman of God all
right that's cool the only issues I have
with that year is that at the end of the
day
um guys don't care about your um
education yeah that's good that you have
you have properties I respect that
that's that's dope but obviously at your
at the age that just level you're at
like yeah you should have something some
thing to show for your time on the
planet see what I'm saying I'm not
trying to be rude yeah then the other
thing you said oh yeah boom like I have
children that's not his children exactly
that's why I'm single yep
again that's another reason but anyway
so boom yeah at the end of the day like
a guy
he that that hasn't really that he
doesn't really get much really like you
can cook that's cool you're a nice
person you're I'm a very good that's
awesome that's awesome and I respect
that but like when you add it then I've
got kids and I'm a good [ __ ]
like reading truly are you really gonna
have kids with a guy that you meet now
probably yeah why not yeah of course I
would but the only issue is I love kids
the only issue is is that like when
women go up in years like the risk of
like problems in pregnancy rises in it
like the like that not in my family hell
no
44. before not in my family no I mean my
mom had my brother when she was 47 years
old and he's absolutely fine and he said
yeah about that yeah but exceptions
don't make rules so you can say that you
can say that you can say that but
everybody knows exceptions don't make
rules that's your opinion it's not
opinion it's actually fact like you can
look up the stats like his way is like
to get them saying like nah I'm not I'm
not saying it's impossible obviously not
and I'm not saying that there's a lot of
guys out there who actually they don't
want kids anyway so it doesn't yeah but
you're the one that pulled that ball but
if you start hold on you start talking
about your mother and that was a benefit
to a guy if you're the one if somebody
wanted kids with me it's okay if
somebody don't want kids with me it's
okay too it's doesn't matter no no
that's cool in it I'm just like saying
I'm decided I'm at my age at the moment
where I'm just happy where I am to be
honest with you no that's cool because
you've already got your kids back so
your guy came to you and he didn't have
kids then what oh Lord a lot of them
actually don't want kids no but I I just
gave you a clear scenario what if the
guy did want kids do you think that oh
let's um let's make kids tomorrow you
know what I mean let's do it
okay is that you yeah is that you yeah
is that you
unfortunately
oh wow
with all due respect so
um next what do you mean all due respect
anyway next on the panel gone uh name
age relationship status my name's
Chantelle I'm 42 I'm a TV and film
actress yep
um
I would say personality and
love because money can't buy love okay
and being kind because I'm a kind person
being a good person being a good person
yeah that's that's respectable then
that's respectable yeah all right uh
next hi my name is Rene Roseanne I'm 23
and what do I bring to the tables are
you asking like what what do you believe
um you offer a guy to the measure that
you can like have like expectations of
like a proper good guy like you don't
say what do you give what does you offer
the guy
okay I will say I'm very fun like I
bring the vibe so if I guys had like a
long day at work or whatever I'll be
there to sort of oh I look cute sorry
um I'll be there to narcissism
she loves herself that's okay and we
love confidence yeah anyway no no one
voice come
um yeah no like
um I would just say
I hate lists and stuff because it sounds
a bit cringy to be honest but I would
just say I bring obviously loyalty for
one
um I bring
just just myself as a person you have to
get to know me I'm not a person to list
out all my personality traits and you
decide it's evil you get to know me and
now it's just a thing of like what do
you think a guy would
um appreciate like highest and what what
are the things that you offer what do
you think is like the selling points
like if you were selling yourself to a
high value man oh my God that's so
cringy it's not cringy it's real life
that is it's not it's actually real name
okay all right okay if I had to say I'll
say definitely motivation for sure
um I would say someone who's not
insecure like I bring the confidence and
like you know you're you're that guy
always because I feel like men sometimes
I have the space to be vulnerable so I
feel like you can be able to talk to me
about whatever because there's no
judgment here
okay that's that's stuff Pleasant that's
Pleasant all right next one
I'm Teddy I'm 25. I think what I would
bring is
um knowledge spontaneity and support
knowledge about what
um as in terms of like what I do or just
generic things
because like you said you said guys
don't look for girls that are like into
education and stuff but there is no I'm
saying guys don't really care in terms
of like oh I'm gonna pick this girl
because she went to University like I
mean some guys may be like that more
inclined but like I think on the
hierarchy of requirements for a guy like
they're gonna value other things above I
went to University
I've dated guys I'm not saying I slept
with them or anything but they did them
and a lot of the time they do look for
women with education yeah trust me I've
spoke to them and they were like what
what they actually do and then when
are they telling you this
just so you give you what you want to
hear oh Lord
because you're coming across as that's
what you you want no no no no it's not
at all because at my age at the moment
I'm 44 years old probably with the
oldest one out of all of you and um I've
experienced a lot of different people
friends
people have dated and stuff like that
and I ask them questions and actually
education is one of the most important
thing that men actually look at they're
lying let me ask you this all right let
me don't ask me why but I'm not I'm not
I'm asking you why I'm not no I'm gonna
ask my question yeah so you're saying
this and oh yeah these guys and again
the exceptions don't make rules and then
also where are these guys at because
you're saying all these things about oh
they really value these but you're
singing they do they do so really and
truly you're just saying anything I'm
not saying anything
if you was if it would be different if
you was like oh my man or my husband or
the father of my children who I'm with
he values that but you're just talking
about guys that you dated yeah
dating doesn't mean that you you need
somebody to be in your life when you're
I don't know what I'm talking about what
why do you need somebody to be here
that's not what I'm talking about we're
talking about what do you offer for in a
relationship what do I offer in a
relationship I mean I'm offering me to
be honest I'm [ __ ] amazing sorry
excuse me sorry I'm amazing why are you
amazing I think I'm amazing I don't need
to tell you why I'm amazing but I think
I am then then if you want to imagine if
your lady here is amazing she's amazing
everyone can be amazing yeah
hold on hold on hold on my bro I put put
the camera on me I feel like bruh it
doesn't matter how you feel dang reality
no you're the one that saying Phil it
doesn't matter how you feel reality is
reality bro if you're winning then you
really have a leg to stand on but until
you're not until you're winning if
you're still just saying if you're still
at the end of the day women is if we
compare mental women and which sex is
gonna be more okay with being alone it's
going to be men because women
usually seek protection and provision
when you are alone and you're in your
house and you hit a bump in the night
Halloween's coming bruv you're gonna
feel like right I wish there was a guy a
big guy there to go downstairs bro bro
you are bro
at the end of the day at the end of the
day I've been protecting myself and my
three children for many many years so
you're saying you prefer it and think
about this you got three kids yeah so
you'd prefer it if danger was to come
you'd prefer it that you go and
investigate the danger and that means
say something bad was happened to you
then your children have nobody above
yeah
they're trying to say that you would
want a man so if danger occurred in your
life like in your home you would want a
man to check it out before you because
darling children my ex-husband you're
not even listening yeah that's it okay
can you just listen to me it's Marshall
bro
hold on hold on yeah at the end of the
day at the end of the day yeah this lady
here was explaining something to you and
you didn't explain bro you're not in
charge here bro I'm sorry no
no
please chill out like are you sure yes I
am
this young I said something and it seems
like you didn't really quite understand
or you wasn't listening and this young
lady here was trying to explain to you
and you cut her off before you even let
her explain it to you so you got to at
least listen and then register what
someone's you're not you see what I'm
saying see this is this is another
reason why here we go you can keep
moaning and I'm gonna keep saying it bro
because you can just cut off your mic as
well oh Lord
no no no no seriously because this is
the thing yeah and I think this
he keeps saying oh Lord every minute bro
like at the end of the day yeah like I
think that a lot of times a lot of times
a lot of people do not really respect
men
and in my in my opinion well you're not
letting me finish what I'm saying on my
own show that I built on my own without
your help
without your help
yeah you talk
no no no no no I don't need your help I
don't need your help I don't need your
help I don't need your help I don't need
your help
let's get the flow back on this man
well stop talking can you stop talking
please I'm asking you nicely or you're
gonna have to leave bro
yeah you might have to leave bro for
real because you know you're not even
wondering you're not even on the show
like I don't understand why you're
dressing up you keep quiet
but like I'm just gonna give you one
more chance you'll have to leave bro
seriously I'm not even trying to do it
to be extra bro like at the end of the
day yeah like this is Marshall and
everyone has been given the rules in it
don't talk over the host yeah and I'm
giving you your chance to speak and you
can smile and laugh whatever and at the
end of the day I was defending this lady
here I was even saying that it's on my
side I'm on her side Jesus Christ bro
what is going on and you wonder why
you're 44 with three kids and you're
single well because you don't shut up
I've been married again and you're not
married now so you're not willing to be
married of course you're going to say
that because you're 44 with three kids
bro yeah talking about oh if I was in
the house and there was a bump
downstairs I would go downstairs what if
you get murked bro now your kids are on
their own bro and she's laughing this is
delusion bro this is a great delusion
bro and this girl here understands it
and she's younger than you and she's
trying to explain it and you won't
listen bro that is mad at your age
that's mad yeah because you are that is
why I survive at 44. right let's see if
you will survive at my age I bet you
can't and why is that and why is that
because you talk too much because I talk
too much yeah you talk on my own show
yeah that you didn't help me create you
brought this out yeah and you took too
much how can I talk too much
hey we're gonna cut the mic bro cause
she's doing too much bro seriously
no no you got a goal bro like seriously
she's got a goal bro like for real no
yeah let's just take it no no no no no
no but she's gonna respect the thing or
she can go you know you go because
you're talking about just move it to my
girl the Batman let's just keep it
moving man
thing like yeah let's give him this kind
of and it's and it goes back to a lot of
times as I said yeah there's no respect
bro there ain't no respect yeah carry on
go on see you extra bit
no respect bro you know what I'm saying
a man if a man a man put the thing back
on me bro like as a man yeah that is
hard in this world every man in here
knows that this this life is difficult
cause yeah just to create anything in
this world is difficult bro then this
random comes and she's talking over the
course yeah she's talking uh blah blah
blah like ah let me ask you the
questions but who are you bro
like you get what I'm saying like you
you could be the G in your life but but
you're not the G here bro so at the end
of the day if you was doing a podcast if
you was doing no seriously I'd be
seriously man
no but you're not even on the show like
what I'm saying stop talking
stop talking
pick me energy
can you just like sit to the side or
side no seriously seriously
you know what you see this whole segment
here yeah this tells a lot this tells a
lot right here this is this is quality
right now and I'm happy I'm happy I'm
actually happy this illustrates a lot of
things you kept saying so anyway
um boom I'm not even gonna vote I'm not
even you see she can't get back to that
question that woman can't stop talking
but let me let me just can I move as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible